so everyone has one of these it's like
your phone graveyard and with mine they
know there's like a couple of Kindles
and then iPad at least one and then
they're all these like phones and once
upon a time these were like the most
important things I had and now they just
sort of in this drawer and I shut it and
I hope they kind of go away as a
scientist I spend a lot of time in
nature I'm also a techie my phone is
pretty much my entire life but it isn't
just an environmental problem once I'm
done using it around 80% of the
greenhouse gas emissions that come from
a smartphone occur before it even
reaches your hands on average Americans
swap out their phones every two years
and about 1.4 billion phones are
produced and sold every year but where
these phones have put together matters
as far as how big their energy footprint
is they make these massive trips around
the world to be built assembled and then
shipped much of the journeys down on
giant container ships that go from
country to country for each step of the
process this happens with most things we
buy that are made overseas we often
associate smog with our cars but
collectively these ships can cause the
same amount of smog and particulate
pollution as all the cause in the world
that's kind of a big deal once a phone
is put together it really isn't designed
to be taken apart and that means it's
hard to repair we are users of
electronics we have participants with
them anymore there's a great history of
tinkering for many other types of
products cars especially you know I have
a really really robust repair and
tinkering community that surrounds us
and you know like getting underneath our
sink and taking things apart in and
figuring how they work and and really
feeling confident about that our phones
are these futuristic looking devices
they almost seem like sci-fi
so it's intimidating to open them up and
inside but fixing you phone isn't
impossible and it could save you a ton
of money along with reducing waste I fix
it Gwendolyn Gay gives tutorials on how
to take apart and fix your electronics
so I went to see her to see if she could
make this process less scary so this is
my personal cell phone that I'm really
okay how many times you open your
personal phone I've opened it a couple
of times
and this is relatively new so I don't I
don't I haven't needed to go in there
other than just out of curiosity like
the reason is everything from banking to
travel everything is on my phone right
and I think that's why we get so nervous
about monkeying with it I think that
that holds people back but I also think
the price of the phone holds people back
knowing that you're voiding your
warranty so if you open your phone this
$600 phone you're just as well if you
don't do it right right so there are
resources if you're brave enough to
repair your phone but what if opening
your phone wasn't so complicated in the
first place
there actually is a company trying to do
exactly this it's called the fair phone
now I didn't even know you could
actually build a phone like that like
you could actually build it like a Lego
set like that but but so that's a fair
Fall Fair phone this is actually the
second one care phone - and they're only
available in Europe and I can actually
do so easy pie we're already in and you
can take out really the battery just
like that Wow
no tools needed okay and then the
display is very similar you just unlock
it here and then you can slide the
display off really so yeah and I can do
that whole process in less than 20
seconds if all I had to do was pull a
few tabs to fix my phone I would be more
inclined to fix it myself
now the fairphone has plans in the
future to release phones in the US but
with no specific date set I'll need to
figure out another option like getting
rid of my old phones responsibly so he
let me ask you different yes let me ask
you to throw why don't I want to
actually throw this away
you don't want to throw this away
because everything inside here is going
to create some kind of waste and it's
going to be toxic waste and if we're
sending it to a place that is recycling
it say we still don't get everything out
of it
what's the most toxic thing in a fall
I'd say the battery for sure if you
remove it wrong it will explode so you
have to take the mask and blow up yes
yeah special right mm-hmm
yes don't do that so what do we do with
our cell phone graveyards now most of us
just hoard them like I do because it
isn't just as simple as your typical
curbside pickup but there are easy ways
to do this in New York and California
stores that sell you a cell phone are
required to accept it back from you for
recycling companies like gazelle will
even buy your old phones off you there's
also organizations dedicated to mapping
out where you can drop your electronics
off companies like Apple are starting to
figure out a better recycling process
they have a robot called Liam that can
take apart an iPhone 6 in 11 seconds
that's roughly 1.2 million iPhones per
year the small screws and other
components can be used again raw
materials like silver found in the phone
circuits can be used in solar panels and
the tungsten that makes your phone pass
can be reused in tools but what if we
could design a phone that just lasted
longer now one of the big reasons why we
replace our phones is because our
batteries just stop holding a charge now
imagine your battery charging in minutes
instead of hours and measuring its
lifespan in decades rather than just a
couple of years University of California
researchers are starting to turn to 3d
printing to make this happen there's the
potential there that you can basically
design the battery to improve its
performance so you could start to play
around with design parameters that you
just didn't have control over in
traditional manufacturing with 3d
printing if we can now print a battery
in any arbitrary shape that
we want what you can do then is design
your phone however you want to design
the phone and then fill it the empty
space in there with your energy storage
material these batteries would be made
using an exciting new compound called
graphene this means we could avoid
harmful mining of materials like lithium
found in today's batteries all of this
technology is in its early stages but it
could radically transform the lifespan
of AI electronics look it's perfectly
common in the airline industry to get on
a plane that's like 30 years old you
can't possibly imagine making a phone
call on a 30 year old cell phone you
wouldn't even know how to charge it
today
and that's the fundamental way we use
technology today and that it's
innovating so fast and built in such a
way that it actually promotes
disposability but I think we're actually
at a very interesting tipping point as
people become more aware companies
become more sensitive to this issue
hey Liam what are you doing for Earth
Day so the next big flashy thing with
our smartphones might not be better
graphics or a faster processor but
instead making them more sustainable
ever wondered about the carbon footprint
of your smartphone or some amazing
materials that could revolutionize your
electronics head over to climate dot
University of California dot edu to find
out more